The Joe Rogan Experience and there have
been
you know maybe
four or five leading hypotheses about
why women do it and uh this is a one
area where I've changed my mind on uh
pretty dramatically so uh early on a
former student of mine Marty Hazleton
who's now a professor at UCLA and other
friends and colleagues like Steve
gangisted and Randy Thornton put forward
this idea that the reason that women do
it is that they're pursuing a dual
mating strategy that is they're trying
to get investment from one guy like the
good Dads but good genes from another
guy
oh wow and and so it's it's uh and is
there any research done on what type of
mate a woman is likely to cheat on
uh well that's that's a good question so
um there's been some and it's not
conclusive but basically the only way
this could work uh and I have to back up
just a second on that we know that
Affairs are very costly for women so if
discovered
they result in infidels result in
violence sometimes they result in
killing you know getting to the killing
I don't know if we want to get into that
maybe later in our conversation
you wrote a whole book on murder I wrote
a whole book on murder yeah uh you know
uh yeah the murderer next door uh but um
uh but also women suffer more than men
if an infidelity is discovered they
suffer reputational damage they suffer
suffer uh sometimes social ostracism uh
it's uh cataclysmic for their
relationship so you know it's in fact
it's one of the leading causes of
divorce worldwide across cultures uh is
if there's a female infidelity
um and so it and so the issue is what
benefit could be so great to a woman
that she's willing to risk all the all
these costs if it's discovered and so
the good genes dual mating strategy
argument could work in principle
um and it would could work if there were
no costs and this is you know one of the
reasons why men and women
commit infidelities in in secret you
know it's been driven underground they
people don't go on Twitter and say hey I
just hey I just had an affair on my
partner you know
um uh it's driven underground people try
to keep it under wraps so they don't
experience the cost and of course there
are costs to men as well by being
discovered they're just not as uh
cataclysmic as they are as they are for
women
so the only way it would work though is
if the getting back to your original
question uh is if there's a large
discrepancy between the woman's regular
partner
and her Affair partner in terms of the
quality of his genes and so with these
um these good genes dual mating strategy
theorists proposed is that there are
certain markers of good genetic quality
they hypothesized masculine features
um and there's a logic behind that they
hypothesize symmetrical features so we
are bilaterally symmetrical species so
normal development in every web you know
our hands or arms our legs grow you know
more or less symmetrically but there are
things that cause deviations from
symmetry so mutations or genetic
mutations can cause deviations
um diseases can cause asymmetries
um and environmental insults in a
variety of ways and so what they the
good genes theorists argue is that if
someone is if a male is very symmetrical
then that's a marker that he's not
experienced the history of disease or
environmental insults or a high mutation
load or has a a what they call a
developmental system that's very kind of
impervious to these insults so even
though they've suffered the slings and
arrows of Outrageous Fortune they still
maintain that symmetry well I think
they're their their problem problems
with that but anyway
um
back to uh to backtrack a second why I
changed my mind so I used to Advocate
this well this seems It's logically
plausible
um
uh but I started to doubt it and I
started to doubt it for two reasons one
is
um some
um replication some larger scale
replications uh of the work started to
fail to replicate uh the original
finding so what they did is how do they
how did they test this what they looked
at is
do women change their preferences when
they're ovulating
so because it's only in that narrow
window of ovulation that she's going to
be getting the good genes
so so what they looked at is women's
normal mate preferences and they tracked
them over the ovulation cycle and do
they change to prefer more masculine
more symmetrical features when they're
ovulating and then go back to their
normal preferences and the initial study
suggested yes they do initial studies
suggested that when women have affairs
it tends to coincide with when they're
ovulating and some other things like
that how do they get gather this data
well it's very difficult and time
consuming data but um you know it
started out with crude methods such as
estimating the woman's time of ovulation
through a back through accounting
backward counting but I mean how do they
get people to even become a part of a
study where they admit that they have
cheated on their husbands oh well so so
that that's a that's a different
question what they these studies just
looked at changes in mate preferences so
what are you talking about Affairs it's
not just changes in May preferences
decision to have intercourse right with
someone other than your husband right
how do you right how do you run a study
right and they have studies like that so
they they haven't said okay yeah no no
so how do they know uh they don't it
it's just do the mate preferences change
at ovulation in the predicted in the
ways predicted by the theory okay so how
would they find that out how would they
find out if a woman's made strategies
changed and for preference has changed
based on ovulation so they basically get
women and then they track them
throughout the cycle uh and so that and
they can do this now they they can do it
through hormonal assays so there are you
know ovulation kits that they can
um assess so what do they have like a
like a survey they fill out like who are
you attracted to today Harry Styles what
about tomorrow something like that Jason
Momoa I must be ovulating right right or
basically they show photographic images
and so the women just rate oh how
attractive is this guy and so what they
and then independently they can assess
masculinity like like Jason how do you
pronounce his name
Aquaman uh yeah he's uh like super
Mexican I remember him I don't think I
saw Aquaman but I remember him from Game
of Thrones yeah
um and uh yeah when Conan the Barbarian
too yeah uh so yeah he would be a
perfect example yeah highly masculine
yeah features you know the um square jaw
heavy brow Ridge ridges you know uh you
know a a good um
shoulder to hip ratio so you know
typically masculine features and so they
would look at do women
rate the photos of these masculine and
symmetrical guys more attractive when
they're ovulating than when they're not
up that's basically what they did
and um
the bottom line so there are some
conceptual problems with that of you
know what does symmetry and masculinity
why are these the sole features that
Mark good genes because they're also
a lot of things that have moderate
heritability it's one of the things we
know from the heritability studies a
zillion things show moderate
heritability
but here's the here's what really
convinced me so so one is the failures
to replicate those studies so the larger
scale studies failed to find those
preference shifts at ovulation
but when you started to when I started
to look at the literature about women
who were having Affairs and the reasons
that they're having Affairs and the
nature of the Affairs there are things
that cropped up like like this
um
79 percent one study found 79 percent of
women
fell in love with or became emotionally
involved with her Affair partner
and to me this is exactly the opposite
of what you'd want if you're trying to
pursue that dual mating strategy idea
you want you you want to get the good
genes and then forget about the guy and
so as not to jeopardize your investment
from the regular partner
um and so and so it's really it's a
design feature that's counter to that
notion it get us up here doesn't it but
it seems to me that you're pursuing this
like as if it's a logical Endeavor
that's based on trying to achieve an
outcome and I think it's far more likely
you're dealing with mental illness
alcohol
you know
emotional imbalance uh extreme desire
for attention narcissism which leads
people to seek out exorbitant amounts of
attention from other people like you
have to take that into account don't you
yeah yeah okay so it's a fair point and
those things
um aren't necessarily inconsistent if
you ask like who has Affairs and what
are their personality characteristics
okay but Affairs happen in all cultures
or virtually all cultures unless the
women are
extremely cloistered as they are in some
cultures where they're like they cannot
leave the home without a male bodyguard
right
but Affairs happen in all cultures and
so some coffee uh sure I'd love some all
right
thank you
so Affairs happen in all cultures yeah
fear is happening in all cultures and so
a competing hypothesis about why and
this is the one I'm currently
um putting my money on if there's a
horse race is what I call the mate
switching hypothesis
uh and and this is the notion that women
who are in relationships
who are where the relationship is going
south
perhaps the partner starts out looking
promising but his fail to live up to his
promise perhaps he becomes an alcoholic
or a drug addict or loses his job or
um or starts um abusing her starts
beating her up
that that women use Affairs as a mate
switching device either to divest
herself of her regular partner
or and or to trade up in the mating
Market to someone who's more desirable
or to make it easier to transition back
into the mating Market on the notion on
the assumption that she'll be able to
find someone more desirable
out there and so and so there's um
at least a fair amount of circumstantial
evidence that supports the mate
switching hypothesis like the one I just
mentioned
um women uh with 79 of women becoming
emotionally involved or falling in love
with their partner this suggests you
know it's not just oh I'm seeking
transient attention
as you mentioned that some women might
do it for that of course
um but it suggests that they're
um
uh forming a long-term attachment to
this other guy rather than the regular
partner so here's here's another one and
this might seem like super super obvious
is that women who are unhappy with their
regular relationship either sexually
unhappy or generally unhappy with their
overall relationship they're more likely
to have affairs now this seems like the
most obvious thing in the world right
yeah sure tell me something I don't your
grandmother couldn't tell you you're
unhappy in the relationship you're more
likely to have an affair but it turns
out the same is not true for men
that is there at least some studies that
show that if you compare men who have
affairs with men who don't there's no
difference in how happy they are with
the relationship
um and that's why you can have men and
just to bring up I don't know movie star
examples
um uh like uh this is an older one but
Hugh Grant was um involved with
Elizabeth Hurley I don't know if you
remember yeah uh that that one and he's
like having sex with a prostitute in L.A
and why why is he uh cheating with
Elizabeth Hurley
um kind of crazy now in his case in that
case uh
the male motivation for Affairs differs
on average substantially from the female
motivation and that is that men are have
this tremendous desire for sexual
variety meaning a variety of sex
partners men tend to have a higher sex
drive
in General on average
and so they try to satisfy so even even
men who are involved with or married to
classically beautiful beautiful women
sometimes have a pairs of people are
very puzzled by this but that desire for
sexual variety is what drives most men
into Affairs and so there's a dramatic
sex difference in why men have affairs
with
um desire for sexual variety pushing
most men into it you know it's like well
I think it was Chris Rock said you know
men are only as faithful as their
opportunity you get a low-cost
opportunity a lot of men act on it you
know if you're like an academic you're
away at a conference you're in a
different town you know some fall into
bed with someone else one night stand a
brief affair and and that's that
but women it's really different of
course some women do it just for sexual
variety too but that's a minority if you
ask if you ask the question why do most
women have a have an affair I think
that's the mate switching notion